to journey the actors who talk to
already Alice and Alan they said that
they were genuinely scared during the
filming of in fear how did you achieve
that and by not telling them what was
going to happen by playing tricks on
them by giving them miss directions and
by setting them against each other
incrementally they got walls stairs they
lost their sword level of trust and they
realized not trusting me was the thing
they have to trust so they would give
certain directions to a janitor and
different lines different pages so they
had to learn to embrace them ten loads I
thing was more brutal in his approach I
mean he would reportedly say
you might slap in the face or get
another idea to do that's what I heard
I'm the same and the idea in testa me
laughs montreal sea dancer in the doll
you know that's a level possibly went
too far for me but I was interesting
that in every film and every show you
know actors bring a lot and they
provides from what's there so all items
make walk there
less and allow them more so
I was influenced by it's a techniques
been tried and tested and drama rain for
me was I had a genre where I can end the
sea you know I could have them talking
but then I did an event attended the
scene something that was actually has
inspiration in real life for you didn't
it the idea behind infinite I mean it
was a story that happened I mean has it
a similar experience amped me but is
very benign and it was a sort of very
friendly practical joke which I then
translated into a more malevolent story
now how does it feel directing this girl
comparatives obviously we know you a lot
for many TV shows big TV shows that
you've been working on how did feel
doing it I was brilliant I'm his
low-budget it was very free and is very
fluid and it was we were making it up as
we went along so it's kind of an
extraordinary experience it's not you
know i mean it doesn't really mean is
this particular film though is different
it's not you know and that is just
because we made it up every day okay two
very very different experience working
on something like Sherlock which always
come back the series we've been working
on it was it like working on such a huge
show like that and experience as a
director I very different if importantly
it's you know there's part of me is very
technical very clinical and I likely
call sort of controlled environment I
like you know they're amazing actors so
I love that side of it this was very
free and I had a lot of fluidity so
they're two parts of me that was
satisfied in the different jobs what it
kind of the pressures of working on
something like Sherlock compared to
working on something like in fear I
think got a responsibility to the fan
base you know genuinely in fear you know
I only feel that today that there's a
fan base Lee or fan that I respect and I
want to know what they feel
Sherlock as the fanbase come with it and
you kind of go [ __ ] I've got to get this
right but it is a script it's not you
know it's written already so what was it
like working with Benedict Cumberbatch
and Martin Freeman on shadow I love them
as he loves and their genius Martin is
his comic timing is beyond second to
none Benedict's very funny and brilliant
and there were moments where I genuinely
felt massively inspired I felt very
lucky actually to be working then if
they difficult when you're working under
such a glare of publicity because
there's been so much kind of people to
find it is Andrew or gonna be there is
no reality what's happening with you
Benedict coming back each other yeah no
that'sthat's fine I mean it was there's
a lot of people who follow you around we
did a few false shots
there will be things that people saw
them not nothing to do is it that way
you handled
you